من شوارع اسطنبول الصاخبة إلى
الممرات الهادئة في
منطقة أنطاليا في تركيا،
هذه هي مدينة منتجع بيليك
التركية التي تضم 22 ناديًا للغولف مع 44 ملعبًا
وفقًا لاتحاد الجولف في البلاد،
ويقع معظمها في هذا
الجزء من ساحل البحر الأبيض المتوسط.
Golfer's Paradise
وهنا ستجد منتجع Regnum
Carrier Golf Resort
داخل الفندق، ولا يمكنك الوصول إلى
ملعب واحد بل ملعبين عالميين،
أقدم نادي جولف وطني، وThe
Courier ربما يكون أفضل
مكان من حيث الأرقام التي
تعرفها  إنه يعمل وأنت تستمتع به، إنه
يتمتع بأفضل طقس لذلك
طلبنا من رئيس راجنوم
كاريا علي سافاك أوزتك الانضمام إلينا في الدورة،
لذلك نحن هنا في صندوق شاي مثير للإعجاب للغاية
أخبرنا أين
نحن الآن  نادي الغولف الناقل في
رقم 16 وأنت على وشك ضرب
الكرة من خلال تجنب الفيلات
إلى المستوى الرابع وفي أحد
أشهر نوادي الجولف في تركيا،
لذلك في هذا الشاي، نحن في الواقع
فوق فيلا شخص ما
وسباحةهم  نعم،
وكنت تخبرني أنه في
الخطوط الجوية التركية المفتوحة،
قفز شخص ما فوق شخص ما قفز للتو بشكل مستقيم،
يبدو الأمر جذابًا للغاية الآن، هذه
لقطة جميلة جدًا
[موسيقى]
تنعم منطقة أنطاليا
بوفرة من أشعة الشمس طوال العام تقريبًا.
يقع موسم الغولف خلال
فصل الشتاء الأوروبي حيث يبحث لاعبو الغولف عن
ملاذ إلى المناخات الأكثر دفئًا خاصة بالنسبة
لأنطاليا، هذه المنطقة من تركيا،
فهي إحدى
الأدوات الوحيدة لجلب السياح في
فصل الشتاء،
أعتقد أن هناك أكثر من 700 فندق في أنطاليا
وضخمة بها  سعة الأسرة
وجميع هذه الفنادق
مغلقة في معظمها في فصل الشتاء
ولكن لعبة الجولف تحافظ في الواقع على أن
فندقنا مفتوح طوال العام.
في The Courier
[Music]
تريد لعب بعض الجولف
يتمتع The Courier بميزة تنافسية، فهو
الملعب الوحيد المكون من 18 حفرة في تركيا والذي يوفر لعبة
غولف ليلية،
ويتيح الجولف الليلي للضيوف ساعات إضافية من
وقت الدورة بالإضافة إلى حداثة
مشاهدة الكرة وهي تحلق ضد
سماء الليل
[موسيقى]